hey guys it's Justine and today we are
chatting about all things Apple watch
Series 3 now the biggest difference
between the new series 3 Apple watch is
that it will now support cellular and
what that means is you're basically not
going to need your phone you will just
need your watch to do all the things
that you would need your phone for like
make calls for instance text messages
you can even listen to streaming music
which is something that I'm really
excited about another thing that is new
is Siri will actually talk back to you
previously you would just get a response
via text but now because of the new
processor that is in the Apple watch
series 3 Siri will be able to respond to
you you won't even need to look at your
phone you do watch your tiny phone on
your arm so cosmetically the old watch
and the new series 3 is the exact same
size the only difference is the back
heart rate sensor crystal is and I quote
two pieces of paper thicker now I didn't
get a chance to try it on and it did not
feel any different at all I did not even
notice that this was bigger I feel like
two pieces of paper is extremely thin
and I think about all the new things
they have packed into the new watch
that's a pretty big advancement
something that I thought was pretty cool
is the biggest question was well where's
the antenna going to be if it's still
gonna be the same form factor the entire
front face of the screen is the antenna
and these little green dots demonstrated
right here but my new friend that I met
at the Apple event that shows you that
it is connected to cellular they share
this amazing inspirational and a very
emotional video during the keynote that
showed all of these people who have used
the Apple watch for the past year in the
past two years and how it's changed
their life there isn't even an instance
where the Apple watch actually saved the
wearer's life they realized that their
heart rate was much higher than it
should have been for a resting heart
rate when you're not doing any activity
and that can sometimes signify something
is wrong so with that that allow this
person to be alerted instantly that hey
I think I should probably go to the
hospital
so obviously you heart rate is a very
important thing to have being monitored
constantly it also plays a huge factor
in fitness and what I love about the new
Apple watch is they're going to be
working together with a gym kit to allow
you to sync your watch data and your gym
equipment together so for example if
you're running on a treadmill that
treadmill is gonna be able to more
accurate release
how long you've been running your
distance your pace all of those things
and a lot of times especially of gym
equipment it's very hard for those
things to be tracked by wearable devices
because it doesn't really know what
you're doing you might be able to tell
it yeah I want to treadmill yeah I'm on
a stair step but it doesn't actually
know the machine itself has the data of
what tasks you just performed so now all
you have to do to be able to get that
data right to your watch is tap and go
they also said that they're going to be
having some support for snowboarders
I've never snowboarded before so I'm not
really sure all of the things that are
gonna be going into that and what you
guys would be looking for we'll be able
to monitor elevation and I'm sure maybe
there's sort of a setting in there that
they could be like hey how fast was I
going down this mountain I'm not sure
but I feel like that information would
be kind of interesting to me if I was
snowboarding I'm also not a big swimmer
but there are some new features for
swimmers they also did a really cool
demonstration of this woman on a
paddleboard in Tahoe and they made a
call to her and the only thing that she
was using in that live keynote was her
watch and it sounded really really good
brand and I don't make many phone calls
but there's a lot of times when I take
my dog for a walk that I like to still
have my phone then I'm holding my phone
walking the dog I'll have a water and
then I have to pick up the dogs there's
a lot of things so if I'm just taking
the dog for a simple walk
I will now just be able to take my watch
and still be connected still be able to
get my text messages my apps and other
sort of notifications that I normally
wouldn't be able to get if I didn't have
my phone with me I'm a huge fan of being
able to stream music from your watch
that's gonna be really cool so using
Apple music they said that you'll be
able to stream more than 40 million
songs you think about that and put that
in perspective that's all that's a lot
of music this is one of the new watch
faces it's a nice gold and it kind of
matches the new iPhone eight gold color
and it looks really really good in
person this watch band is called spicy
orange it's so great this is one of the
new sport loop bands that they just
introduced as well and it's a new type
of model that it's made of like this
breathable fabric so when you feel it it
kind of feels like velcro but like a
really soft velcro it's kind of spongy
it has a little bit of push back I'm not
really sure how to explain it and velcro
is right here so this allows you to pull
it as tight as you can all the way
around your wrist now I have a problem
though because I have
small wrists which I probably should pop
down to the 38 because it would make a
lot more sense but I do like having a
bigger screen I'm basic but I usually
don't run into this issue of the watch
bands being too big because most of the
sport bands they come with two different
sizes they come with a small/medium and
a medium/large band so you're able to
adjust that to the size of your wrist
and I was at the Apple campus and I was
so excited that I was like I am gonna
treat myself and I'm gonna buy this
Hermes Apple watch band and one that I
thought I was getting was this loop band
but this loop band is only made for the
38 the 42 comes in the one that I was
unboxing and I didn't know this at the
time so when I opened it I was a little
bit surprised because I was expecting
that it was going to be the loop and all
the way around a little deceived by the
display so unfortunately when I tried it
on I was like man this is really really
big problem with getting the 42
millimeters I put it on the tightest
setting and everything and I wore it for
a little bit I was like I have to return
those if there's no way that I could
justify spending this much money for an
Apple watch bands it does not even fit
so my suggestion to you guys if you are
planning to get one of the more
expensive watch bands do try them on
first go to the Apple store give it a
shot because I don't want you to have
the same problem that I had while we're
on the topic of watch bands they also
introduced a bunch of new colors of
watch bands I love being able to switch
up my watch bands I could care less
about what I'm wearing I care way more
about what my watch band is but since
I've been wearing this Nike sport loop
one it's been my favorite it's a very
breathable it still does get a little
bit sweaty but it's way better than the
ones without the holes that's why I'm
really excited about the sport loop
because that is something that I feel it
will absorb sweat and you'll have to
worry about being like hmm another day I
gotta loosen up my Apple watch because
my arm is sweating in addition to the
new gold face they also have this gray
ceramic I'm a huge fan of the ceramic
watch basis I have the white one which
I'm sure many of you guys have watched
me unbox here previously I love the
ceramic it feels great on my wrist it is
a little bit heavier than the aluminum
and it is a little bit more expensive so
we're deciding which Apple watch is
right for you I think what it really
comes down to is price and do I want
something a little bit smaller and
lighter and is it necessary to have LTE
I don't think it's a how to present
necessary to have LTE especially if this
is your first album watch but
this is your first Apple watch I think
it's gonna be a really cool feature to
have to really not have your phone if
you work in a job or for say a class you
will be able to have access to pretty
much everything that you would have on
your phone on your wrist let's take a
look at some of the new watch bands that
they introduced this one here is my
favorite it is so beautiful it is called
the fuchsia
it's a beautiful leather fuchsia of it I
feel like I'm probably gonna have that
same issue that I have with this that I
had with that Hermes version then you
Sport loop here are some of the new
colors this flash looks awesome here it
is spicy orange I love it electric pink
midnight blue dark all of sports
seashells sport I feel that will
probably get dirty I've never had any
problems with any of these white bands
getting dirty because they are that
silicone so it's very easy to clean but
what this I feel like it's more of a
fabric so I mean I would probably just
throw it in the wash when I'm doing
laundry I don't know what will happen to
it I can probably do it test to see the
outcome so maybe I'll get the white get
it dirty see if I can clean it and see
what happened so I can do a test for you
guys to see if it's okay to throw your
Apple watch loop fans in the wash
people also tell you that you're not
supposed to throw like tennis shoes in
the watch but all of my Nikes I throw
them in like every other week and guess
what they're fine here are some of the
new sport bands we have a rose red book
blue sport band the ultra violet dark
olive soft white I like this fog sport
fan that's a really good color pink
midnight blue black it's still a really
huge fan of the Nike sports fans so
here's a few other new colors they have
the pure platinum and the black pretty
sure they had this one before but I
still really liked that look this one
looks to be like a dark blue here's a
few of the woven nylon these all look
really great as well there's really so
many customizations that it's insane
here's in the leather here's the cosmos
blue
there's my baby pink fuchsia other
colors these all look really good than
modern buckle I'm more of the sporty fan
and here's their Mezen leather they're
so beautiful
but here's the problem 38 millimeter
only I did not know and they all look
great no real question is how much of
these things gonna cost so we're gonna
look here and this is the breakdown of
all of the models they have
you can get it with GPS or the GPS and
cellular we've got this series three
this is the silver aluminum with the Fox
for fans that's a really nice look like
that looks super slick course the rose
gold is by far one of my favorite colors
ever although I'm probably going to be
getting the ceramic one again so to
differentiate between the Apple watch
seriously the cellular and the previous
versions without cellular they decided
to put a red dot on the crown I'm gonna
be completely honest with you I do not
like the red dot at all red is my least
favorite color I think red is a really
great accent color but in this sort of a
scenario I don't think it is it all
mostly because there are so many
different colors of Apple watch bands
and different combinations and some of
those things as a designer myself I
would never put red with some of these
colors like it's just like it's like a
contrasting color and it's just I am NOT
a fan at all but with that being said
I'm still gonna get one anyway I do
think that it was smart on their part to
put something cosmetic that would
differentiate the two but I feel like
the red is there nothing else that you
could've come up with like there's gotta
be something something else that you
could have done beside the red either
way here's that lineup here's the silver
aluminum case with the GPS they've also
got the rose gold the Space Gray Space
Gray aluminum it's a gold look at that
and it looks incredible they also have
some of the Nike watch series so here
they are here here's the silver aluminum
case with pure black oh my gosh the
Space Gray the silver aluminum Space
Gray and looma do with OGS you get the
point and then we have the Hermes Apple
watch series these ones are super
expensive because of obviously the brand
and the leather bands then we have the
Apple watch edition so that brings us
here to the white ceramic and B gray
ceramic and these both start at $12.99 I
pick areas to see what that number
combination is of the Apple watch faces
and the fans and the GPS and the
cellular like how many different
combinations can you make with all of
these cuz it's gotta be pretty high
another thing that I thought was really
cool is they announced this air power so
it's kind of like a power Wireless
connecting match you can put all of your
devices onto it and it will charge them
at night
at night because I feel like that's most
of the time that you're going to be
using that when I'm on the go or during
the day I usually have like a movi
charger with me and I don't usually
charge my Apple watch on the go one of
the things that I forgot to mention is
all of the watches that were at the
Apple event we're running watch OS 4 and
there's a lot of new features in watch
OS 4 which makes it pretty exciting I
never did install the beta on my watch I
thought about it but I think I'll just
wait at this point for the actual thing
to come out if you guys can't tell I'm a
huge Apple watch fan I wear mine almost
every day everywhere I go I love
dressing it up and dressing it down I
have worn it so many times on red
carpets usually sometimes it's you know
with an outfit that you should wear an
Apple watch with but I will wear it and
a lot of people ask me what do I use my
Apple watch for mostly and it's weird
because I don't really know if there's
one set thing that I use it mostly for I
feel like it integrates seamlessly into
my life it's sort of second nature I
just kind of look at it I see what my
schedule is I go do set activity I love
being able to use it for navigation when
I'm driving in my car it kind of gives
you that little hey the gentle tap of
you have to turn soon which is great
because I'm not very good with
directions it's also great for when I'm
in a city and walking I can just have
those walking directions on my wrist and
I don't have to have my phone up so if
you've ever been skeptical about the
Apple watch I think now is the time they
have worked out all of the bugs all of
the kinks and they have finally figured
out the place for this thing anyway this
was a very long video and I talked a lot
and I probably could keep talking but
I'm gonna end it here and as soon as I
get my hands on one of the Apple watches
I will make a video about it and I'll
let you guys know my full review and all
of my thoughts but just for now I'm
gonna go ahead at this video now I'll
see you later
I can't believe I still edit my own
videos what am I thinking I'd have a lot
more free time to play destiny if I
didn't edit
did I like it
[Music]